[Music]
some of the things that's already been
happening is Realtors are calling
families who lost everything offering
them to buy their their property and
their home for pennies on the dollar
just pennies on the dollar so it's
pretty offensive to us that people won't
even give us some time to grieve
properly
[Music]
let's go
first necessity we have of course was
water our water system was shut down at
the time so we gathered the Bunches of
water juices sodas we have fresh fruit
from all over the island here papayas
bananas fresh breadfruit this is a big
staple for us Hawaiians
the recovery from this tragedy is
proceeding and it's proceeding extremely
vigorously as you know the tragedy
occurred on the 8th late
immediately we asked for support and the
world has stepped up our communities
have stepped up and before I go too far
I want to say how much we appreciate
those who supplemented the things that
we were unable to do in the early days
[Music]
thank you